hello welcome to this video playing our
for rock eighth rack whatever let's see
a kiddo
just try something else okay this is not
very threatening
it's a rather decent line for black e
for
okay
so essentially plays a maraca see by dre
takes on c6 that should not be very
threatening honestly
how do we do this then 97 you know
certainly possible
in a 5 this 95 no sorry
let's go a 5
you
okay if I can play Queen 85 in this
situation I'm quite happy it just trades
the bishops
you okay
ah
you
okay so f4 is what he
wants to play
this yeah absolutely
you
I I did not really appreciate how good
disease
it is I mean it's not like I'm lost or
so but it makes it makes make some sense
really in their form it's quite quite
dangerous
my idea is valid at all
tink tink
[Music]
and wanted to play e5
soon
[Music]
ninety-five
come on
it is strategically strategically
desirable to play e5 it just has to work
out technically which I'm unsure if it
does
okay and it's not very dangerous I guess
that is not so dangerous
you
[Music]
now maybe I can actually play Kansai -
it's not bad
I can provoke
[Music]
okay b3 I guess he he should we just do
that why must be three so bad
you
I didn't see why I didn't see why
avoided these three
didn't feel so terrible
I didn't see like a window porn or
something I can't take another home
Oh
mm I can't exceed six
I don't like to give him c6 I mean not
for materialistic reasons but just
because I want to cover everything okay
I don't think I should go to e5 this is
just that this is the most harmonious
way of setting this up
so let's do this then the Queen is just
a good piece only five
keeping d1 under control and there is a
four you know there is this pressure and
if I can get a three and a 390 for FY if
a 43 that is a somewhat of a threat
well I noticed I don't know
it's not a good square really for the
nights ago diem
at least I didn't see a turn and see a
square
you
my haircut not square
makes it very difficult then if you lose
this space of the night the beach upon
should be pretty bad
okay so Queen takes on a a 2h you with
some this pawn is say close close to
promotion okay but anyway there is also
Queen to XP to
really what is that doing
you
you
okay well this is increments yes so the
twelve seconds are not really an issue
sometimes I have
technically but I'm confident that this
would road that this will work out
justno stalemate or something
it's about the only danger in this
position
nay look G to look f7 stuff
like that
you
no stalemate
I'm absolutely it's absolutely possible
that I do some stupid stalemate stuff
that's not to go there
Oh
ah
okay it was a little bit a little bit
odd damn something so let's let's have a
look here this should be okay for black
yeah it's the CAPTCHA on c6 should mean
that black should be okay now the Ponyo
is covering d5 so I don't think it
should be a problem so 22 a4 a5 I'm
surprised that the engine gives white
0.6
I thought it would be gone anyway so
Luke see one in four yeah so I expected
p3 to happen but didn't didn't didn't
occur so okay I was able to do this you
should age six Queen to b6 king each one
yeah and him I mean this is a good plan
here go with f4 just what he did right
after that was surprising age age three
I was surprised because I don't really
threaten to put something on to g4 so
okay but the engine doesn't mind no
plate each five and now from here it
gets very interesting
Kim
now f5 I absolutely underestimated f5
that's very true
yeah it's a bits problem a real problem
you know in the overall structure
wouldn't be such a big deal but the the
concrete position and its tactics are
definitely in White's favor what is my
move is the problem if I play something
routine let's say I go here yeah to to
cover some dark squares and maybe coffee
fiber so he can put this on the board
attack this and I cannot a threat I
cannot do this because take stakes look
f6 is certainly killing your head is
killing this is just a disaster area so
this attack here is a problem
I mean h6 is a bad move but I have to be
sure that I can cover this and I don't
know how the engine wants to do this
which is not really what I am intended
to do and now even doubling is annoying
so that is better for Wyatt no no doubt
yeah he took and this is not good I know
I'm I think quite nicely positional to
t1 multi-age and bish Bishop f3 this is
a move that simply you cannot play just
to passive you have to do something more
active the engine wants to play c5 which
is interesting context we never force
actually good for white yeah I cannot
move that and queen e5 also cannot more
so after c5 I cannot actually take it
then c5 is strong but then c5 is strong
ok it seems that this is a playable
position and get it back but I don't
know if I would have found that and when
witches like attack Bishop by 3 is just
not a move it just not a candidate move
so passive there should be six winned e3
I was expecting b3 here is it so
terrible
it's not good I just have the better
structure and good squares okay Quinn d3
was played and share just gives me upon
and I took another part which was maybe
not the best yeah it is not like by the
column just 25
94 is stronger
I mean it's better I've got to pawn so
even if I return one okay Queenie five
that wasn't there was a mistake
seems I was unsure Queen a fire is
better I that make some sense a queen a5
is basically a tempo on the queen but 94
what is four wise 94 such a strong move
because of i-5 home so let's say I cover
it
the nicest I just sorry the other one
comes 96
and somewhere here
it's not clear to me at all I mean he
must do that but it's it's a bit a bit
strange
yes it's quite geni winning yeah a - I
thought it would win Red Queen me - yes
is enough and I'm just I'm just material
it's it's there was one point I weigh I
could have taken G to makea be careful
whoops
and it's a draw it's the kind of thing
that could happen yeah good okay no stay
away please thanks a lot for watching us